What's it really like to live with ME or Chronic Fatigue Syndrome? In this episode, my guest Dr. Beth shares her personal experience of managing this often misunderstood condition. From what a bad day really looks like to treatment options that can actually help, plus stick around right to the end so that you can learn the one piece of advice you should never follow if ME or CFS is on your radar. Hope you find it super useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
患上肌痛性脑脊髓炎（ME）或慢性疲劳综合征（CFS）究竟是什么体验？在本期节目中，我的嘉宾贝丝博士将分享她管理这一常被误解病症的个人经历。从糟糕的一天究竟是什么样的，到真正有帮助的治疗方案，请大家收听到最后，这样就能了解到，如果你的生活中出现了ME或CFS，有一条绝对不能听从的建议。希望你能觉得这期节目非常有用。你好，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》。
I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Today, my guest is Dr. Beth Godwin, a qualified clinical psychologist who somewhat had her life turned upside down when she started to experience symptoms of ME, chronic fatigue syndrome. We're going to dive right in to my chat with Beth. And please, if you do find it helpful, please do drop a like, drop a comment, consider sharing this content. If you're on Spotify, drop in a question or a comment. If you're listening on Apple Podcasts,
我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天，我的嘉宾是贝丝·戈德温博士，她也是一名合格的临床心理学家。当她开始出现ME（即慢性疲劳综合征）的症状时，她的生活可以说是被彻底颠覆了。接下来，我将与贝丝进行深入的交谈。如果你觉得有帮助，请务必点赞、留言并考虑分享这些内容。如果你使用的是Spotify，请留下你的问题或评论。如果你在使用Apple Podcasts收听，
please do rate and review. And if you're on YouTube, please do make sure you're subscribed, like the video, drop a comment, especially if it resonates with you. And following or subscribing to a show wherever you get your podcasts, really is the kindest thing you can do for free
请务必给出评分和评论。如果你在YouTube上观看，请确保你已经订阅了频道、为视频点赞并留言，尤其是当这些内容引起你的共鸣时。在任何你获取播客的平台上关注或订阅节目，对于你所欣赏的任何播客创作者或制作者来说，真的是你能做出的、完全免费的最贴心的支持。
for any podcaster or creator that you rate. Let's dive in and catch up with my chat with Dr. Beth, and I will see you on the other side. Hi Beth, so lovely to have you along. Thank you for being here. Thank you so much for having me. And thank you especially for being here because I know with your condition, it means that, you know, you have to choose where to spend your energy. So thank you for sharing some
让我们深入了解我与贝丝博士的交谈，我们在节目另一端见。嗨，贝丝，很高兴你能来。谢谢你来到这里。非常感谢邀请我。特别感谢你能抽出时间，因为我知道由于你的病情，这意味着你必须选择把精力花在什么地方。所以感谢你与我们的听众分享一部分
of your energy with our audience. You're very welcome. So before we begin, could you tell us what ME forward slash CFS is? I can and I can try and pronounce it as best to my ability, but they do make it very difficult by giving them long medical terms. So ME is myalgic encephalomyelitis, also known as chronic fatigue syndrome or CFS or ME. And it's often thought of as just feeling tired and that's largely due to the chronic fatigue syndrome title that has given it that misconception but actually it's quite a complex and chronic neurological illness that can
精力。不客气。那么在我们开始之前，你能告诉我们什么是ME/CFS吗？我可以，而且我会尽我所能去发音，但他们用了很长的医学术语，这确实让发音变得很难。所以ME是肌痛性脑脊髓炎，也被称为慢性疲劳综合征或CFS或ME。人们通常认为它只是感到疲劳，这主要是因为慢性疲劳综合征这个名称造成了这种误解，但实际上它是一种相当复杂且慢性的神经系统疾病，可以
affect the brain, the nervous system and now they're even looking down to a cellular mitochondria level. But the main features that you will tend to see are fatigue, un-refreshing sleep, no matter how much sleep you've had you don't wake feeling refreshed from the night before. We have what we call post-exertional malaise, also known as PEM, which we could talk a little bit more about, cognitive impairments like brain fog or concentration or forgetfulness, pain and there's also a crossover with orthostatic intolerance so people's blood flow not behaving as it should so I'm also diagnosed with POTS which is postural orthostatic tachycardia Syndrome so yet more
影响大脑、神经系统，现在他们甚至将其研究深入到细胞线粒体层面。但你通常会看到的主要特征是疲劳、睡眠无法恢复精力——无论你睡了多久，第二天醒来都不会觉得精神焕发。我们有所谓的运动后不适，也称为PEM，我们可以对此进行更多讨论，还有认知障碍（如脑雾、注意力不集中或健忘）、疼痛，并且它与体位性不耐受也有重叠，这意味着人们的血液流动没有按应有的方式运行，所以我也被诊断患有POTS，即体位性心动过速综合征——所以还有更多
technical terms which basically means that my heart and my blood flow doesn't do what it should do when I am standing up or when I'm walking around the way it does with somebody without orthostatic intolerances. And it's quite a tricky diagnosis to receive because there's no tests for it. So it's a diagnosis of exclusion where everything else that you can possibly think of has been ruled out probably over a number of years before you're finally given the diagnosis. And what we know now is that it frequently follows in some people a viral infection where the body hasn't fully recovered. And that's what happened in my case. And it's now what we're seeing with COVID and long COVID as well.
技术术语，这基本上意味着当我在站立或四处走动时，我的心脏和血液流动不像没有体位性不耐受的人那样正常运作。而且这是一个相当棘手的诊断，因为目前还没有针对它的检测方法。所以它是一个排除性诊断，在最终确诊之前，可能需要经过好几年，将所有能想到的其他病因都排除掉。而我们现在所了解的是，它在某些人群中经常继发于病毒感染，此时身体尚未完全康复。这就是我经历的情况，这也是我们现在在新冠肺炎以及长新冠（Long COVID）患者身上看到的现象。
Yeah. And I guess I was definitely thinking about the parallels and I think long COVID, it feels like long COVID is more accepted and more validated. Whereas with ME, I feel like there is more stigma, but I'm talking about that as a mental health professional and as kind of perhaps knowing people have had ME, that might feel quite different when you are a psychologist and you have a diagnosis of ME. Could you talk to me about stigma and kind of, you know, what people say about it or think about it? This isn't just, you know, I've not long had lunch. This isn't just, oh, I'm having the post lunch slump, is it? But I think perhaps some people
是的。我想我当时确实在思考它们之间的相似之处，而且我觉得长新冠似乎更容易被接受和认可。然而对于ME，我感觉存在更多污名化。但我是作为一个心理健康专业人士，以及可能认识ME患者的人在谈论这一点。当你自己是一名心理学家，并且被诊断患有ME时，这种感觉可能会非常不同。你能跟我聊聊这种污名化，以及人们对此是怎么说或怎么看的吗？这可不仅仅是——我刚吃完午饭不久——这不只是“哦，我正经历午后疲惫期”，对吧？但我认为可能有些人
think it is that. Yeah, absolutely. I think people just see it as feeling a bit tired or needing more rest and it's so much more complicated than that so you know mild version of ME might look like a little bit more rest, extra rest in between activities but it can also be managing that cognitive fog. It can be mobility difficulties that somebody finds it hard to get around, limiting activities all the way to the severe end of ME where somebody can be bedbound because they don't have the energy or the capacity to lift their body out of the bed, they can't tolerate
会觉得它就是那样。是的，完全如此。我认为人们只是把它看作是觉得有点累或需要更多休息，但它的复杂程度远超于此。你知道，轻度ME可能表现为在活动之间多休息一会儿，但它也可能需要应对认知迷雾。它可能是行动困难，导致某人觉得四处活动很艰难，从而限制活动；严重时甚至会发展到重度ME，患者只能卧床不起，因为他们没有力气或能力把身体从床上撑起来，无法忍受
light or sound, they might require full-time care and I think you're right there is difference in the stigma towards long COVID than there is EMI and possibly that's because of the times that we're in where EMI was called yuppie flu in the 80s and it was looked at as more kind of laziness. Whereas with the long COVID there's been so much more research done to show the effects of COVID and post viral fatigue. Yeah, thank you for illuminating us on that. And I think until really meeting with you today, even, I hadn't appreciated how it can be, you know,
光线或声音，可能需要全天候护理。我觉得你说得对，社会对长新冠的污名化程度与对ME的污名化程度存在差异，这可能是因为我们所处的时代不同。在80年代，ME被称为“雅皮士流感”（yuppie flu），当时它更被视为一种懒惰的表现。而对于长新冠，人们已经进行了大量的研究，展示了新冠病毒和病毒后疲劳的影响。是的，谢谢你为我们阐明这一点。而且我觉得直到今天真正见到你之前，我甚至都没有意识到它可以是
psychological, physical, like everything, identity, I guess even because it's not necessarily something that people are born with, it's something that they have to adapt to and perhaps the people and the systems and maybe even the work or occupational environments around you perhaps no longer fit or people's expectations of you. Maybe they miss the old you, but you likely also really miss the old you too. likely also really miss the old you too. Like it's a whole sea change, isn't it? Absolutely and it impacts on every part of somebody's life. It's not just on one part.
心理上的、生理上的，就像方方面面一样——我想甚至连自我认同也是如此，因为这不一定是人生来就有的东西，而是你不得不去适应的东西。或许你周围的人、系统，甚至工作或职业环境可能不再适合你，或者大家对你的期望也变了。也许他们怀念那个曾经的你，但你可能也同样非常怀念曾经的那个自己。就像经历了一次翻天覆地的巨变，对吧？绝对是的，它影响了一个人生活的方方面面。不仅仅是某一个方面，
It's work, it's education, it might impact on how much you can do, it might impact on the type of work that you can do and obviously at the severe end people aren't able to work at all and the person that you were before it might not be the person that you can be now. So prior to my diagnosis I was always described as busy, you know, working full-time in the NHS and weightlifting four or five times a week and then my hobbies on top and then my socialising on top and all of that busy identity has to change and adapt and the people around you have to also adapt to those changes too and recognise that you have these energy limitations and there can be a lot of grief for not only the life that you have lost but
它关乎工作、教育，它可能会影响你的工作量，可能会影响你能从事的工作类型，而且显然在病情严重的情况下，人们根本无法工作。你之前的那个自己，可能已经不再是现在的这个能胜任各种事情的自己了。所以在确诊之前，我总是被形容为大忙人，你知道的，全职在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）工作，一周进行四五次举重训练，再加上各种业余爱好，还要兼顾社交，而所有这些忙碌的身份认同都必须随之改变和适应。你周围的人也必须适应这些变化，并认识到你的能量是有限的。这会带来巨大的悲伤，不仅是为了你已经失去的生活，
also the life that you had planned and thought that you would have might now look very different. Yeah, it's kind of reminding me that when I was at uni I think we studied multiple sclerosis and there was some evidence that people with a type A personality were more likely to get an MS diagnosis. Do you know if there's any correlation for any traits in ME and CFS? Yeah there does seem to be some trends with perfectionist types, the people who probably are going to get an infection and then don't take the time to recover because they're so keen to return to work. And that was, you know, speaking from my experience, that is definitely what happened with me where I had a viral infection of some sort, but
也是为了你曾经规划好、以为自己会拥有的那种生活，现在看起来可能会截然不同。是的，这让我想起我上大学时，我们似乎研究过多发性硬化症（MS），有证据表明A型性格的人更有可能被诊断出患有MS。你知道ME和CFS的某些特质之间是否存在类似的关联吗？是的，完美主义倾向的人群似乎确实表现出一些趋势，这些人可能在感染病毒后，由于急于返回工作岗位而没有花时间好好恢复。说实话，结合我自己的经历，我得承认这绝对就是发生在我身上的情况。当时我感染了某种病毒，但
you know, that couldn't stand in the way of work. I had to get back to work and see my clients and rush back too soon. And then obviously became unwell again. And later down the line, this has obviously impacted my nervous system somehow. Yeah. And I think, you know, the audience listening to or watching this will be doing so either because they are struggling with these symptoms or they care about someone or they're working in mental health.
你知道的，工作不容耽搁。我不得不重返工作岗位，去见我的客户，过早地匆忙回去。然后很显然，我再次病倒了。在后来的日子里，这显然以某种方式影响了我的神经系统。是的。我想，收听或观看这个节目的观众，要么是因为他们正在与这些症状作斗争，要么是因为他们关心这样的人，要么是从事心理健康工作的人。
Especially when we are caregivers, we can often feel that pressure to hurry back before we're fully ready because we don't want to let people down or we've got to support the team or everyone else is off on long-term sick, you know, and it's, you know, we can understand these pressures, but actually really thinking about when I've had sick leave, am I fully ready to return, not to light duties, but am I fully ready to do my job? And I often think even when I've had a cold or I've had, you know, a vomit bug or something, even after the exclusion period where I'm technically allowed back, I think you always need a day of being out of bed and kind of mobilizing from your sofa to your kitchen and back again. But then you also need an extra day to really strengthen your body and your mind because it reminds me of when I'd
特别是当我们作为照顾者时，我们经常会感到必须在完全准备好之前就匆忙赶回岗位的压力，因为我们不想让人失望，或者我们需要支持团队，或者其他所有人都因为长期病假而不在岗，你知道的，我们可以理解这些压力。但实际上，我们需要认真思考：当我请过病假后，我是不是真的完全准备好回去了？不是去从事轻松的轻体力工作，而是我是不是真的完全准备好胜任我的工作了？我经常觉得，即使我感冒了，或者得了胃肠炎之类的病，哪怕过了官方规定的、技术上允许我回去上班的隔离期后，你也总是需要有一整天的时间离开床铺，从沙发走到厨房再走回来，活动一下筋骨。但除此之外，你还需要额外的一天来真正强健你的体魄和心智。这让我想起两年前我
broken my arm two years ago and the physio told me afterwards that even kind of as short as a couple of days in bed gives the body the message actually we're wasting energy by continuing to fuel these muscles and so it tries to preserve its energy by stripping that energy back from the tendons, which means that your tendons start to contract. And she said that if you're not getting out of bed, if you're not doing things, if you're not flexing your body, it then takes a whole lot more effort to stretch them again. It's not two days. This might be weeks or months if you've been in bed for a week or for example.
摔断了胳膊，理疗师事后告诉我，仅仅在床上躺短短几天，就会向身体传递这样的信号：“由于继续为这些肌肉提供能量是在浪费能量，我们得把能量省下来。”于是身体试图通过从肌腱中抽回能量来保存体力，这意味着你的肌腱开始收缩。她说，如果你不下床，如果你不活动，如果你不拉伸你的身体，那么以后想要重新把它们拉伸开，就要付出多得多的努力。这可不止两天的时间。如果你在床上躺了一个星期或更久，这可能需要几个星期甚至几个月。
And you know, if you're resting a lot, then your body is constantly getting the message, oh, we don't need to, we don't need to power these legs, we don't need to have that available. And, you know, I think to cut a very long rambling story short, When we're going back to work, we really need to make sure that we are mobilizing normally, that we are really up to speed, that our brain fog has lifted enough to be able to sit with clients and not have them to be constantly wiping our nose or thinking about ourselves. And we've got to be well when we return to work and actually that will stay with me now even more thinking about we deserve to rest and actually our future self, which then hopefully wouldn't get a condition like this, would thank us for that. Absolutely, and I think that is a huge thing that we need to recognise within this hustle
你知道的，如果你一直在休息，那么你的身体就会不断收到这样的信号：“哦，我们不需要，我们不需要为双腿提供动力，我们不需要保持那种能量储备。”而且，简而言之，当我重返工作岗位时，我们真的需要确保我们的活动能力恢复正常，我们的状态真正恢复到全速运转，我们的脑雾已经消散到足以坐在客户面前，而不会让他们看到我们不停地擦鼻涕或者满脑子只想着自己。当我们重返工作岗位时，我们必须是健康的。说实话，这会一直伴随着我，让我更深刻地认识到：我们有权休息。而且，实际上我们未来的自己（如果未来能幸运地避免患上这种疾病的话）会为此感谢我们的。绝对是这样。我认为这是我们在当下这种内卷文化中需要意识到的巨大问题。
culture that we're in. And I remember one of the nurses that I was working with at the time said to me, if you're not careful, you're going to get post-viral fatigue. And I just didn't consider the long-term outcome that going back to work, which sounds so simple, could have had. But if I had heard that advice back then, perhaps I wouldn't have rushed back as quickly as I did. Amazing. And I think especially when we're working for the NHS, we have to know that
我记得当时和我一起工作的一位护士对我说：“如果你不小心的话，你会得病毒后疲劳的。”而我当时根本没有考虑过重返工作岗位（听起来这么简单的一件事）可能会带来的长远后果。如果我当时听了那个建议，也许我就不会像当时那样匆忙赶回去了。太惊人了。而且我认为，特别是当我们为NHS工作时，我们必须知道
we can have usually up to six months on full pay, not always. And we wouldn't necessarily encourage people to take sick leave that didn't need it. But I know that even more recently, there's been kind of counting episodes of sick leave and people are only allowed so many episodes in a year but I still would say if you've already if you've had the episode because you've been on well you might as well make sure that you are well because certainly in the NHS it's not necessarily the days that are counted it is the episode so get yourself well that was really good advice but at that time I guess you couldn't, you couldn't heed it. It felt maybe it felt irritating or silly. Like how did that feel when she
我们通常可以享受最多六个月的全薪病假（虽然并非总是如此）。我们不一定会鼓励不需要的人去请病假。但我知道，更常见的情况是，现在会对病假次数进行统计，每个人一年内只被允许请一定次数的病假。不过我还是要说，如果你已经因为生病而请了一次假，你最好确保自己是真的痊愈了再回去，因为在NHS，通常计算的不是天数，而是病假次数。所以，先把自己的病养好吧。这真的是个很好的建议，但在当时，我想你根本无法、也无法听进去。这听起来可能让人觉得恼火或愚蠢。她当时说这话时，你是什么感觉？
said that? It felt like an exaggeration or perhaps overprotective or it just didn't seem real to me at that point that something that you just deal with, you know, like a flu or a glandular fever or a bug, you know, we just think, you know, that's what happens in life and you just go back to normality. So it just didn't feel within my, I guess, my headspace at that time that that was actually important. And although that virus was 2015, 2016, I think around there, my symptoms of ME didn't actually start to show up until 2020. Whatever was going on internally was just sitting in the background there until it became
这感觉像是一种夸大其词，或者或许是过度保护，在那时，它在我看来根本不现实——就像你平时应付的事情一样，比如流感、腺热或普通病毒感染，我们总是认为：“生活就是这样的，你挺过去就能恢复正常了。”所以在当时的心理状态下，我根本没有觉得那其实是一件多么重要的事情。尽管那次病毒感染发生在2015年或2016年左右，大概那个时候，但我ME的症状直到2020年才真正显现出来。无论身体内部当时发生了什么，它只是在后台静静潜伏着，直到病情变得
so difficult that it would start to show up and present itself. Thank you. I'm sorry to hear how long you've struggled with this. Just to help us to kind of paint a picture, would you be able to give us an idea about perhaps what a bad day looks like for somebody with this diagnosis? I can. It's one of those diagnosis where everybody is so different, depending on where they are on the kind of mild to severe spectrum but also in the types of symptoms that they get
如此严重，以至于它开始显现并表现出来。谢谢你。听到你一直在与这个病痛抗争这么久，我感到很遗憾。为了帮我们大致了解一下情况，你能否跟我们分享一下，对于患有这种诊断的人来说，糟糕的一天通常是什么样的？可以的。这是一种因人而异的诊断，具体情况取决于他们在轻度到重度光谱上的位置，同时也取决于他们所承受的症状类型，
because everybody's symptoms are so different. So some people might not be able to get out of the bed, might not be able to shower, might not be able to use the bathroom, you know, make a meal, they might have to block out light from their room if it's becoming too much sensory overload. Other people might just, I say just, like it's simple, it's not. Other people might need to plan breaks, they might need to take themselves away from loud environments. Myself, at a difficult day, can look like pain. So I get pain more than I get fatigue, whereas other people can get fatigue more than they get pain. It's
因为每个人的症状都大不相同。所以有些人可能无法下床，无法洗澡，无法使用洗手间，无法做饭；如果感官超载太严重，他们可能必须把房间里的光线完全隔绝。而另一些人可能只需要——我说的“只需要”听起来很简单，其实不然——另一些人可能需要规划休息时间，需要让自己远离嘈杂的环境。对我而言，糟糕的一天可能会表现为疼痛。相比于疲劳，我经历更多的是疼痛，而其他人可能疲劳多于疼痛。只是
just different in how it presents itself. And then I can have a few months where I'll have a sore throat every day and then that passes and then I'll have few months where I have nausea every day and then that passes. I don't know why it changes but it does. I only ever really get the fatigue part of this diagnosis if the flu in that you feel heavy and you have no energy just without the snots and the coughs but that physical feeling is the same. I can also pick up infections very easily which is something that I didn't know until I had it in that my immune system doesn't protect me in the same way that somebody without this diagnosis might have. So that requires being quite careful around people and if I do pick up an infection
表现形式各不相同。而且我可能会有几个月的时间，每天醒来都会喉咙痛，然后这种症状过去了；接着又会有几个月的时间，每天都感到恶心，然后这个症状也过去了。我不知道为什么它会变，但它确实在变。只有在染上流感时，我才会真正体验到这种诊断中的疲劳部分——那种浑身沉重、精疲力竭的感觉，只不过没有流鼻涕和咳嗽，但那种身体感受是一样的。我也很容易感染各种疾病，这是我在得病之前不知道的事情，那就是我的免疫系统不像没有这种诊断的人那样能够很好地保护我。所以这要求我在人群中必须相当小心；如果我真的感染了某种病毒，
I don't quite recover like I used to. It takes a lot longer. Forgetfulness, brain fog, I suppose some people might feel the emotional side of having all of these different symptoms, you know, it's not just physical, it's not just the cognitive symptoms, it's then dealing with them. And grief is a part of that, like I've already mentioned, a massive amount of apathy, you know, if you're tired, normally you don't have motivation and you don't want to do things. So when you're in a crash, it's very difficult to feel like you can be bothered about most things until you can come out the other side of that crash and the frustration at being held back from the things that you want to do but either know that you can't
我无法像以前那样完全恢复，需要花费长得多的时间。健忘、脑雾——我想有些人可能会感受到伴随所有这些不同症状而来的情绪压力，你知道的，这不仅是生理上的，不仅是认知上的症状，还要去应对它们。正如我之前已经提到过的，悲伤是其中的一部分；还有极度的冷漠——你知道的，如果你很累，你通常就没有动力，不想做事。所以当你处于崩溃期时，你很难对大部分事情提起兴趣，直到你能走出那个崩溃期，并且会对被阻止去做自己想做的事情而感到沮丧，即使你明知道自己
or that you shouldn't for now. Yeah, I think even the identity around yourself and your relationship to work, I know I would find that really challenging adjusting because I often say, psychology for me feels different. So I might say to my children or my husband, oh, I've got work, I'd rather stay in bed and read my book, especially because I'm reading a really good book at the moment. But whenever I'm with a client or doing something like this, like I really love it. And is that something that's different? Like you can't almost switch on the gear that you used to be able to kind of keep in the tank.
做不到，或者现在不应该去做。是的，我觉得甚至连你对自己的身份认同以及你与工作的关系都变了。我知道我自己会觉得这种调整非常具有挑战性，因为我经常说，心理学对我而言感觉是不一样的。所以我可能会对我的孩子们或我丈夫说：“哦，我有工作，我宁愿呆在床上看书，”尤其是因为我最近正在读一本非常棒的书。但每当我面对客户或做类似这样的事情时，我是真的很喜欢它。这有什么不同吗？就像你几乎无法像以前那样随心所欲地切换档位，把精力蓄在油箱里。
Do you know what I mean? To be able to give your best to your work. To be able to do that, it has to be very carefully planned. So I have to think about rest breaks. I have to think about how many people in a day. I have to think about if I'm seeing that person, what am I doing after that? What am I doing before that? Have I eaten?
你知道我的意思吗？为了向你的工作倾注你的全部最佳状态。要做到这一点，必须经过非常仔细的规划。所以我必须考虑休息间歇。我必须考虑一天之内要见多少人。我必须考虑如果我要见这个人，在这之后我要做什么？在这之前我要做什么？我吃过东西了吗？
Have I hydrated? So it just takes a lot more forethought than I used to have to do. Yeah. And it's reminded me of trying to sort out, you know, it's going to be a real nightmare trying to sort out, you know, it's gonna be a real nightmare trying to sort out with your mates when you're actually gonna meet up if you all live in different parts of the country.
我补充水分了吗？所以这比我以前习惯的做法需要更多的深思熟虑。是的。这让我想起试图安排……你知道的，这绝对是一场噩梦，试图去安排……这绝对是一场噩梦，当你和你的朋友们住在国家的不同地方时，到底什么时候能聚在一起。
Frankly, if you all live in the same part of the country, it's still a nightmare, modern lives, right? But I was looking through my diary and I was like, I can't do that weekend because actually I've got simply read and then the next day I've got a calligraphy course and then I'm going out for dinner the next day. You, I guess, would kind of probably not choose to do three activities like that all together. But also how is it to look ahead and book anything and put money on the line for things
坦白说，即使你们住在同一个地方，现代生活也依然是一场噩梦，对吧？但我当时正在翻看我的日程表，心想：“我那个周末去不了，因为事实上我那天有阅读安排，然后第二天我有书法课，再过一天我要出去吃晚饭。”我想你可能不会选择把这样三个活动连在一起做吧？而且，去展望未来并预订任何东西、为那些最终可能去也可能去不了的事情花钱，又是一种什么样的体验呢？
that you may or may not be able to do ultimately? Yeah, I can't tell you the amount of concerts, gigs, theatre tickets that I've just had to write off or try and last minute resell because it's not something that you can totally have control over. You know, I can plan until the cows come home, you know, I can really put thought into what that week looks like if I've got an activity, but it's what it is on the day. Some days that planning pays off and some days the body has other ideas and says, no. It does make you kind of a flaky person that you have to cancel last minute, which I never have been. I think there's perhaps, flaky gets a bad reputation really, or it's not the most appropriate word here. It's that
是的，我简直无法告诉你，有多少次音乐会、演出、剧院门票，我不得不直接作废，或者尝试在最后一分钟转手卖掉，因为这不是一件你能完全掌控的事情。你知道的，我可以把计划做到天荒地老，我可以对如果有一个活动的那一周应该怎么安排进行深入的思考，但最终还是要看当天身体的实际情况。有些日子，这种规划会有回报；但有些日子，身体却有它自己的想法，会说：“不。”这确实会让你变成一个“容易放鸽子”的人，你不得不临阵取消，而我以前绝不是这样的人。我想，或许“放鸽子”这个词名声不太好，或者在这里并不是最贴切的词。事实是：
you're unwell. You can't do it. If you'd suddenly come down with a vomit bug, people would understand, wouldn't they? But I guess it's, oh, how many times is Beth going to say she's tired? But actually that's really dismissive, isn't it? And that's not fully embracing you or embracing the person with this condition. And actually, we need to get over ourselves really, and think, well, how can I support Beth? You know, perhaps, rather than going out for dinner, perhaps if I was to say, can I bring us dinner? And I'll, you know, perhaps we'll make sure we're finished by 8pm. Would that feel okay? Or is that not okay? But I want to see you, I want to spend time with you, but I want to meet you where you are. Is that kind of a helpful accommodation?
你生病了，你做不到。如果你突然得了胃肠炎，大家都能理解，对吧？但我想，人们可能会想：“贝丝又要说她累了多少次了？”但实际上这种想法非常轻蔑，对吧？那并没有完全接纳你，也没有接纳患有这种病症的人。事实上，我们真的需要克服这种偏见，去思考：“好吧，我该怎么支持贝丝呢？”你知道，也许与其出去吃晚饭，不如我换个方式说：“我把晚饭带过来好吗？我们可以确保在晚上8点前结束。”这样感觉可以吗？还是说这样也不行？但我真的很想见你，我想和你共度时光，但我希望在你所处的状态下去迎合你。这种变通会有帮助吗？
Yeah, and actually my friends are so understanding and so supportive in that our relationships have had to be very much text-based now. You know, we'll send memes, we'll send gifts, you know, we'll do things like that that I can stay in touch and I can do whilst resting. And there's lots of accommodations so people will either come to me rather than going for a walk like we used to or I met up with a friend the other week for a coffee and it was, you know, thinking about where we sit there that's not going to be too loud so I don't have to overly concentrate on trying to hear her while they're banging the coffee grounders together. And also her accommodation was so lovely that she checked in with me
是的，实际上我的朋友们都非常理解和支持我，以至于我们的关系现在不得不很大程度上转为文字沟通。你知道的，我们会发表情包、发动图，我们会做这些我既能保持联系、又能在休息时进行的事情。而且有很多变通的方法，比如朋友们会选择来看望我，而不是像以前那样一起出去散步；或者上周我和一个朋友见面喝咖啡，我们会在选座位时考虑到“这个地方不能太吵”，这样我就不用在咖啡研磨机轰鸣的时候，费劲地去集中注意力听她说话了。而且她非常体贴，会主动关心我，
and said, you know, where's the pain levels? You know, do we stop here? Do we make another day now? You know? It was really appreciated. Thank you. That sounds lovely. I'm going to push for a few more. Are there any other ways we can support friends or support maybe people in our team or our family who might maybe not even have this diagnosis yet, but they are heading in that direction or do already have that diagnosis? Have you got any other top tips for us, if you can think of any? Yeah, I would say patience is the massive top tip. You might not get a response straight away. You might not get a text back. You might not hear from them for a while. And knowing that that is nothing to do with you and everything to do with how their symptoms are that day, that
问我：“疼痛指数怎么样？我们现在该停下来了吗？我们要不要改天再聊？”这真的让人非常感激。谢谢。听起来真温馨。我还想再多了解一些。除了这些，还有什么其他的方法可以支持我们的朋友、团队成员或家人吗？他们可能还没有确诊，但正朝着那个方向发展，或者已经确诊了。如果你能想得起来的话，还有没有什么其他的实用小贴士可以分享给我们？有的，我会说“耐心”是最重要的小贴士。你可能不会立刻得到回复，可能收不到回信，可能有一段时间听不到他们的消息。而你需要明白的是，这与你毫无关系，完全取决于他们当天或那一周的身体症状。
week. Patience is a huge part of it and understanding. And asking, you know, there's nothing wrong with asking, you know, how can I help? How can we adjust this, meet up this activity? You know, how do we make it different? Do we change the place? Do we change the time? Because often I know my symptoms are worse in the morning than they are in the afternoon. So that person is the expert in themselves and what is going to happen to their symptoms and how to manage them. So just ask. Great advice. And as you were talking, I was thinking, well, obviously a lot of my audience are aspiring psychologists. And I was thinking about, well, what if there's an aspiring psych or someone that wants to retrain to become a qualified psych? Watching or listening to this and thinking,
耐心是其中极其重要的一部分，理解也是。还有去询问——询问并没有错，比如：“我能帮什么忙？我们该如何调整这次聚会或活动？我们怎么才能改变一下？是换个地方还是换个时间？”因为我深知我自己的症状通常早上比下午更严重。所以，患者本人才是最了解自己、最清楚自己的症状会如何发展以及如何应对的专家。所以，直接问就好了。很好的建议。当你在说话的时候，我在想，很显然我的许多观众都是有志成为心理学家的人。我在想，如果有一个有志成为心理学家的人，或者想重新接受培训成为合格心理学家的人，
can I do this with this diagnosis? But it also made me think about, I know that some courses, I think Lancaster, I know are one, are offering part-time clinical psychology doctorates now. So in part-time clinical psychology doctorates now. So I think it equates to 0.7 rather than 1.0 whole-time equivalent. And that's like four years and three months or something rather than three years. I know everyone is different, but do you think that sort of accommodation could help us to kind of get people with ME, CFS in our psychology workforce? Yeah, I think any flexibility has got to be helpful. And also thinking about the type of caseload or thinking about, even with lectures, are you planning in enough breaks? Can you take yourself off somewhere to have a rest during those breaks? I know
在观看或收听这个节目时会想：“带着这个诊断，我能做到这一点吗？”这也让我想起我所知道的一些课程——我知道兰卡斯特大学就是其中之一——现在提供非全日制（part-time）临床心理学博士课程。所以这相当于全日制工作量的0.7，而不是1.0。这大概需要四年三个月左右的时间，而不是三年。我知道每个人情况各异，但你认为这种变通方式能否帮助我们将患有ME或CFS的人吸纳到我们的心理学工作队伍中来？是的，我认为任何形式的灵活性肯定都是有帮助的。而且还要思考案例量（caseload）的类型，或者甚至考虑到在听讲座时，你是否规划了足够的休息时间？在这些休息期间，你能否抽身去某个地方休息一下？我自己
myself when I was training breaks were socialize, go for a walk, you know they were filled with more activity. So thinking about how do you plan those rest breaks into that structured day so that you can adjust your energy limits accordingly and it's absolutely doable because there was somebody in my year that successfully navigated training and graduating alongside ME, as difficult as I'm sure it was. Not that I realized at the time. No, hindsight is 20-20 vision, as they say. But, yeah, certainly, I think even going on to a cohort and forming those
在受训期间，休息时间往往意味着社交、散步，你知道的，休息时间也被各种活动填满了。所以要思考如何将这些休息间歇规划到结构化的日程中，以便相应地调整你的能量上限。这绝对是可行的，因为在我同届的学生中，就有人在患有ME的情况下成功完成了学业并通过了培训毕业，尽管其中的艰难可想而知。虽然当时我并未意识到这一点。不，正如人们所说，事后诸葛亮永远是百分之百准确的。但是，是的，当然，我认为即使是进入一个学员群体并与大家建立这些关系，
relationships with people, that can feel like a very active process. It's very engaged. And I know every time I've started a new job and a new placement or done something new, it really messes with my sleep because my brain is like fizzing with the names, with the faces, with the smells, with the people. And so if already your sleep is not restful and then you're doing all of these new things, I'm guessing to use a term that I know you're familiar with and we will explain shortly, takes a lot of spoons. Yes, absolutely takes an awful lot of spoons and an awful lot of planning those spoons. Yeah, so let's talk about spoons. I know this was an idea that I think came about
那也会感觉是一个非常积极主动的过程，需要高度投入。我知道每当我开始一份新工作、新的实习或做一些新事情时，它真的会打乱我的睡眠，因为我的大脑就像在滋滋冒泡一样，塞满了各种名字、面孔、气味和人群。所以，如果你的睡眠本就已经无法恢复精力，然后你又在做所有这些新事情，我想用一个你所熟悉且我们稍后会解释的词来形容的话——这会消耗大量的“勺子”。是的，绝对需要消耗大量的勺子，并且需要对这些勺子进行大量的规划。是的，那我们就来聊聊“勺子”吧。我知道这个概念几年前在社交媒体上兴起，
on social media a few years ago for thinking about managing your energy levels when you have chronic fatigue, but you might well know more about the origins for that and be able to talk us through it there. So the origins were, I'm terrible with names and my brain isn't gonna let me remember them, but it was a woman who was explaining energy limiting conditions. So the idea is that within a day, you have a limited amount of spoons
用于思考当患有慢性疲劳时如何管理自己的能量水平，但你可能对它的起源了解得更多，并能为我们做个梳理。它的起源是——我对记名字实在不在行，我的大脑不让我记住这些——是一位女士用来解释能量限制型疾病的理论。这个想法是，在一天之内，你拥有数量有限的勺子，
and we imagine those spoons to be units of energy and you may wake up with less spoons than others on some days but we certainly have a limited amount of spoons compared to somebody without an energy limiting condition. You then take those spoons or units of energy and you have to decide and plan your day where you are going to spend those spoons. So getting up maybe a spoon, having a shower maybe a spoon or two spoons depending on the severity of your illness, taking a phone call maybe a spoon and it's important to recognize that it's not just about physical energy, it's also about social energy, emotional energy, mental energy and sensory energy. So how much our environment might use those
我们可以把这些勺子想象成能量单位。某些日子里你醒来时拥有的勺子可能会比其他日子少，但与没有能量限制型疾病的人相比，我们的勺子数量绝对是有限的。然后，你拿着这些勺子或能量单位，必须做出决定并规划你的一天，把这些勺子花在什么地方：起床可能需要一勺，洗澡可能需要一勺或两勺（这取决于你病情的严重程度），接听一个电话可能需要一勺。而且重要的是要认识到，这不仅仅关乎体力，还关乎社交能量、情感能量、心理能量和感官能量。所以，我们的环境可能会消耗这些
spoons also and when you consider all of those things thinking where is the most important place to spend those spoons and once they're gone they're gone. Whereas with somebody who doesn't have a energy limiting condition you might have a rest and you might have gained some spoons back but unfortunately with most conditions you don't gain them back. You are then resting until the next day where you may wake up with the same spoons, less spoons, more spoons, you'll find out in the morning. Oh, it's really hard to have control, isn't it?
勺子，因此当你考虑所有这些事情时，要想清楚把这些勺子花在哪个地方是最重要的。一旦它们用完了，就真的没了。而对于没有能量限制型疾病的人来说，你可能休息一下就能恢复一些勺子，但不幸的是，对于大多数这类疾病，你是无法把它们恢复过来的。你只能一直休息，直到第二天醒来时，你可能会收获同样多的勺子、更少的勺子，或者更多的勺子——这一切只有到了早上才会揭晓。哦，这种缺乏控制感的感觉真的很艰难，对吧？
Yeah, it just takes a lot more thought and this is very much where the idea of pacing comes in. So, pacing is a strategy where you are going to balance how you rest and how you do activity. So again how you spend those spoons. Otherwise if you spend too quickly or too much you end up in that post-exertional malaise or PEM. So there is a very tricky balance of not overdoing but also not doing too little either. And it can look like planning rest in between activity. It can look like breaking down a task into more manageable chunks. So even things like getting dressed in the morning, you know, first most people just
是的，这确实需要更多的深思熟虑，而这正是“节奏调整”（pacing）的概念发挥作用的地方。因此，节奏调整是一种策略，通过它你可以平衡你的休息和活动，也就是如何明智地使用这些勺子。否则，如果你消耗得太快或太多，你最终就会陷入运动后不适（PEM）的状态。因此，在“不过度透支”和“不过于缺乏活动”之间存在着非常微妙的平衡。这可能表现为在活动之间安排休息，也可能表现为将一项任务拆分为更容易应付的小块。所以甚至连早晨穿衣这样的小事，对大多数人来说，
stand up and get out of bed. But for a lot of people with energy-limiting conditions you might have to break that down a little bit. You might have to sit up first, then you might have to put your legs over the bed, then you might be able to do some standing up and sitting back down, then you might be able to collect the clothes and bring them back to where you are when you're sitting down. You also might have to cancel or decline plans like we've already talked about in order to protect the energy that you have.
大家通常只是站起来下床。但对于许多患有能量限制型疾病的人来说，你可能需要把这个过程拆解一下。你可能需要先坐起来，然后把腿挪到床边，接着可能需要试着站起来一会儿再坐回去，然后你可能才有力气去拿衣服并把它们带回你坐着的地方。为了保护你仅存的能量，你可能还不得不像我们之前讨论过的那样取消或推迟计划。
Yeah, thank you. It's like a whole other world, isn't it, really? That's what I'm learning. Before I met my father-in-law, he had had a diagnosis of ME at that time. That's what he called it at that time. But he did get better. So I've been in his life probably about 16 years, something like that. So he got better before I met him. Is that common or is that uncommon? How much to people kind of are they able to recover and be perhaps the person they used to be before this condition? It's tricky really because it's so hard to get the statistics on even a diagnosis that it's hard to get the statistics on recovery. From my understanding, I see an ME service, from my understanding some people may have a lifelong condition, some people may end up in sort of a
是的，谢谢你。这简直就像是另一个完全不同的世界，对吧？这就是我正在了解到的。在我认识我公公之前，他在那个时期曾被诊断患有ME。那是他当时对这种病的称呼。但他后来康复了。所以我在他生命里的时间大概有16年左右，诸如此类。因此他在我认识他之前就已经康复了。这种情况常见吗？还是不常见？人们究竟有多大可能康复，并且能够恢复到患病之前的状态呢？这其实很难说，因为甚至连获取该诊断的确诊统计数据都极其困难，更不用说获取康复率的统计数据了。据我了解——我是在一个ME专科门诊就诊的——据我所了解的，有些人可能会终身带病，有些人可能会过上
leading a better life but have a risk of relapse and some people may build themselves back up to a life where they are free of symptoms. I'm not sure on the statistics of each one because the statistics are so difficult to get hold of, of who even has ME. Yeah, and I guess, you know, it reminds me of that episode of Friends where Joey Tribbiani kind of can't do certain things for a period of time because he's doing a medical research thing. Then as soon as he can do those things, he goes back to his old ways of being. It's like then if you didn't have an ME presentation, CFS, would you necessarily want to spend all your time filling in research about it? Would
更好的生活但仍有复发的风险，而有些人则能够将自己重新调理到一个无症状的生活状态中。我对每种情况的确切统计数据并不清楚，因为关于到底有多少人患有ME，这些统计数据太难获取了。是的，而且我想，这让我想起《老友记》里的那一集，乔伊·崔比亚尼（Joey Tribbiani）因为参加一项医学研究，在一段时间内无法做某些事情。然后一旦他可以做那些事了，他就回到了以前的生活方式。这就好比，如果你不再表现出ME或CFS的症状，你还会愿意把所有时间都花在填写关于它的调查问卷上吗？
you want to go out there and embrace the life that you've missed, you know? And I think it's, yeah, research is great so long as we can really get a sample of people, but it's not, it's not always easy and not always possible. Yeah, absolutely. And I suppose a bit like Joey, a lot of people end up in that boom bust cycle where they feel better. So they do all the things that they've missed and then they really have a good time, which then leads to a crash and and that's what we call the boom bust cycle. And it seems like you know if you
你难道不想走出去，去拥抱那些你错过的生活吗？我觉得，是的，研究固然很好，只要我们能真正获得具有代表性的样本人群，但这并非总是轻而易举，也并非总是能够做到。是的，完全如此。我想这就有点像乔伊那样，许多人最终会陷入那种“大起大落”的循环中（boom bust cycle）：当他们感觉好一些时，就会去做所有他们错过的那些事情，玩得极其开心，而这随之就会导致病情的崩溃。这就是我们所说的“大起大落循环”。看起来，如果你
can pace as well as you can to break that cycle you have more of a chance at recovery. And kind of just before we kind of start thinking about you and what you're doing at the moment, is there any medication that's helpful? Is there any evidence based approaches like therapies that actually help to move the needle on this? Or is this all just kind of, I don't know, I guess acceptance and kind of biding your time? Support's tricky. I suppose it depends where you live on what's going to be available. I'm very lucky in that I have a local ME service that supports me. In terms of medication,
能尽可能好地把握节奏来打破这个循环，你就会有更大的康复机会。在我们开始讨论你目前的生活状态之前，我想问问：有没有什么药物是有帮助的？有没有什么循证方法（比如疗法）能够真正推动病情的改善？还是说这一切基本上都只是……我不知道，我猜大概是学会接纳并耐心等待时机？寻求支持是一件很棘手的事。我想这取决于你住在哪里以及能获得什么样的医疗资源。我很幸运，当地有一家ME专科门诊在支持我。在药物方面，
that isn't really a route that seems very popular, in that it's hard to know what to medicate and a lot of the medications that have been tried with myself don't do anything, but that's always going to be a intervention called graded exercise and I'm bringing it up because I want people to be aware that this is not something that should be recommended and if you hear it from a doctor, change doctors. Because it used to be an intervention where you start a small amount of exercise and you build up and the idea is that your body accustoms to that but actually what we found is that because of post-exertional malaise where it can hit you the day after or the day after that is it was actually making a lot of people worse. So it was taken out of the guidelines but unfortunately some people still are given it as
这似乎并不是一条很受欢迎的途径，因为很难知道该用什么药来治疗，而且在我身上尝试过的许多药物都没有任何效果。但总会有一种干预手段被称为“渐进式运动疗法”（graded exercise），我把它提出来是因为我想让大家意识到，这不是应该被推荐的方法；如果你从医生那里听到这个建议，请换个医生。因为过去这种干预方法是：从少量的运动开始并逐渐增加，其理念是你的身体会适应这种锻炼。但实际上我们发现，由于运动后不适（PEM）会在运动后的第二天或后天发作，这种方法实际上让许多人的病情变得更糟。所以它已经被从指南中移除了，但不幸的是，有些医生仍然会把它作为建议提供给患者
advice so I'm bringing it up as a warning label that if somebody offers that as an intervention to ignore it and find somebody else. In terms of treatments I suppose CBT can be helpful for some people. I found because of my training, acceptance and commitment therapy has probably helped how you do that which is often a difficult thing to adjust to. Yeah absolutely thank you for illuminating us I think it's really interesting to think about what not to do so I really like that idea it's kind of like the graded exposure thing that people talk about in CBT but actually we don't we don'tT, but actually we don't want to do that. We don't want to do systematic desensitisation for people with ME or CFS. It's very helpful to know.
建议，所以我把它作为一个警告标签提出来，如果有人把这作为一种干预手段，那就忽略它并去找别人。在治疗方面，我想CBT（认知行为疗法）对某些人可能会有帮助。我发现由于我的培训背景，接纳承诺疗法（ACT）可能更有帮助，它能帮助你适应那种通常很难适应的状态。是的，绝对如此，谢谢你启发了我们，我认为思考什么不该做真的很有趣，所以我真的很喜欢这个想法，这有点像人们在CBT中谈论的分级暴露疗法，但实际上我们不想这样做。我们不想对ME（肌痛性脑脊髓炎）或CFS（慢性疲劳综合征）患者进行系统脱敏。了解这一点非常有用。
Could you tell us a little bit about you and what you're doing now professionally, Beth? I can, and it's very relevant because I think if I didn't have my ME diagnosis I wouldn't have created this new venture of life for everybody because I was quite happy doing one-to-one work in my therapy clinic and it's only when I've really had to start thinking about how I manage my energy that I've had to reduce my caseload and I'm not able to see the same amount of people that I could before. So it's really made me think about how do I help people in a way that protects my energy as well. So life for everybody isn't solely about helping people with chronic illness. I do share my ME experiences from time to time with it,
贝丝，你能给我们介绍一下你自己以及你目前从事的专业工作吗？可以的，这非常相关，因为我认为如果我没有确诊ME，我就不会为所有人开启这段全新的生活事业，因为我以前在我的治疗诊所里做一对一的工作挺开心的，直到我真的不得不开始思考如何管理我的能量时，我才不得不减少工作量，我无法像以前那样接待那么多的人。所以这真的让我思考，我如何在保护自己能量的同时去帮助别人。因此，“为了所有人的人生”（Life for everybody）并不仅仅是为了帮助患有慢性病的群体。我会不时地分享我患ME的经历，
but it's a lot more about diet culture and about being stuck in diet culture. And it teaches people to listen to and respect their body. And nothing teaches you faster than a chronic illness to be able to do that but life for everybody is actually about how you do that within the diet culture that we're living in so when we live in a society that accepts that there are good foods there are bad foods like all the fear-mongering around processed foods that I'm seeing at the moment, that you have to burn off food through exercise, that you have to be thin if you're worthy or healthy and life
但它更多的是关于节食文化以及陷入节食文化的内容。它教会人们倾听并尊重自己的身体。没有什么比慢性病更能让你更快地学会这一点，但“为了所有人的人生”实际上关乎你如何在苏醒的节食文化中做到这一点，当我们生活在一个接受“有健康的食物、有糟糕的食物”的社会中时，就像我目前看到的围绕加工食品的所有骇人听闻的言论一样，认为你必须通过锻炼来消耗食物，认为如果你有价值或健康你就必须变瘦，而生活
for everybody is helping people to question some of these accepted beliefs and unlearn the myths and we focus on practical tools about how to listen to your body, how to eat without guilt, how to move your body for joy rather than burning off calories and punishment and learning how to accept and respect the body that you're in now even if it doesn't match this ideal that the world is telling us we should have. Amazing, that sounds superb. Where can people learn more? If you've got social media, where's the best place to catch up with you?
为了所有人，就是帮助人们性质地质疑这些被普遍接受的信念，并摒弃那些迷思。我们专注于实用的工具，教你如何倾听自己的身体，如何毫无负罪感地进食，如何为了快乐而非燃烧卡路里和惩罚去活动身体，并学会接纳和尊重你现在的身体，即使它不符合世界告诉我们应该拥有的那种理想状态。太棒了，听起来好极了。人们可以在哪里了解更多？如果你有社交媒体，去哪里找你是最好的方式？
Yes, you can find me on Facebook at Life for Everybody and we also have a Facebook group there where people can come in and can openly share what they're struggling with with their food and with their body image and you can also find me on Instagram under the same name, Life For Everybody. Amazing, I will make sure that I link all those details in the show notes and they'll be appearing on screen for people on YouTube as well and I know in business sometimes it can be a really helpful idea to have like something really amazing as a freebie so that people get a real vibe for who you are and the way
是的，你可以在Facebook上通过“Life for everybody”找到我，我们在那里还有一个Facebook群组，人们可以在里面加入并公开分享他们在食物和身体形象方面所挣扎的事情，你也可以在Instagram上用同名“Life For Everybody”找到我。太棒了，我一定会把所有这些详细信息链接在节目简介中，它们也会在YouTube上为观众显示在屏幕上。我知道在商业中，有时候拥有某种真正惊艳的免费赠品是一个非常有用的主意，这样人们就能真正感受到你是谁以及你的表达方式
that you talk. Is there anything that people who are interested can grab from you? Yeah, absolutely. So on my Facebook page and on the Instagram in the bio section there is a free guide that introduces diet culture myths and how we might start to see them in our day to day life so you can start spotting them and also give some helpful hints and tips of how to start speaking more compassionately about your body. Sounds ideal and I'll make sure that that link is in the description
感兴趣的人可以从你这里获取什么吗？是的，绝对可以。所以，在我的Facebook主页以及Instagram的个人简介部分，有一个免费的指南，介绍了节食文化的迷思以及我们如何开始在日常生活中注意到它们，这样你就可以开始识别它们，同时它也提供了一些有用的小建议和技巧，教你如何开始用更多同情心的话语来谈论你的身体。听起来很理想，我一定会确保该链接放在描述中
and in the show notes for this episode as well. Thank you. Thank you so much for your time. This has been a fascinating, eye-opening look at all things kind of ME and fatigue for me. So thank you for illuminating us and for spending some of your spoons with us today. Thank you very much for having me. You're so welcome. Thanks for being here. Thank you so much to Beth for her time in speaking with us. And please do consider following Beth on her social media where she is life for everybody and grab her free resource too, which sounds brilliant. If this content has resonated with you, please do start some conversations
以及本集的节目简介中。谢谢。非常感谢你抽出时间。对我来说，这是一次引人入胜、大开眼界的体验，让我了解了所有关于ME和疲劳的事情。所以感谢你启发了我们，并感谢你今天分出一些精力与我们交流。非常感谢邀请我。不用谢。谢谢你能来。非常感谢贝丝抽空与我们交谈。请务必考虑在社交媒体上关注贝丝，她的账号是“life for everybody”，并且去获取她的免费资源，听起来非常棒。如果这段内容引起了你的共鸣，请务必开启一些对话
in the comments on YouTube. Please do rally around one another. And if this is content that resonates with you, let me know by sharing it, by watching it, by liking it, by engaging with it, because that helps me know that you would find similar content useful in future too. That said, I would love to know
在YouTube的评论区。请大家务必互相支持。如果这段内容能引起你的共鸣，请通过分享、观看、点赞和互动来让我知道，因为这有助于让我知道你在未来也会觉得类似的内容很有用。话虽如此，我很想知道
what content you would find helpful. so please do make that known too. To hear other stories about clinical psychologists and other types of psychologists who have struggled with adversity and managed to get their way to be qualified, please do consider checking out the Clinical Psychologist Collective book, which you can get links to in the show notes or description. And if you are an aspiring psychologist and you would like to get my free guide for supercharging your applications and your interviews it's my psychology success guide and you can get that by going along to my website www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk It's the aspiring psychologist Poshkitz
什么内容对你会有帮助。所以请务必表达出来。要想听到其他临床心理学家以及经历过逆境并成功获得资格认证的其他类型心理学家的故事，请务必考虑查看《临床心理学家合集》一书，你可以在节目简介或描述中找到获取链接。如果你是一位有志成为心理学家的人，并且想要获取我的免费指南来为你的申请和面试赋能，这是我的心理学成功指南，你可以通过访问我的网站 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk 来获取。这是有抱负的心理学家Poshkitz栏目
With Dr. Mary and Drift There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与玛丽博士和德里夫在一起。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。